[Music]
more people are playing dota 2 right now
than in the last two years and it isn't
because of dota
[Applause]
gee it isn't because of arteezy's major
antics
the duel is not the cliff Oh easy Clift
once again there means or even a broken
new character being released
dear are you
[Music]
it's because of a custom game mode that
just needs you to install DOTA an
exhilarating strategy game known as Auto
chess okay it's okay QT because it sells
for full price it sells for full price
you can buy like right now yeah
what started as a mod for dota players
to toy with in their spare time has
exploded into one of the biggest games
on Steam with over 6 million subscribers
and a standalone mobile release on the
horizon we are witnessing the birth of a
new genre one that could do to dota with
dota into Warcraft
[Music]
dota Auto chess is a terrible name but
that hasn't stopped it from becoming a
runaway hit in just four months the mod
was released in January by dro tous to
do a team of Chinese and Taiwanese
developers who were previously best
known for some moderately successful
dota BOTS but with auto chess it was
clear that they'd stumbled onto
something special get in there
ea we're [ __ ] putting her right in
front and she's gonna [ __ ] it clear the
show the thing that immediately said it
apart was its strategic debts you and
seven other players use gold to buy and
draft the team of carefully selected
heroes who Duke it out across a series
of chess boards with no actual player
input once a match starts that's a
mentality I realize wait a second
okay oh my goodness this has never
happened before the thing is even though
you can't control these heroes or as the
dev team calls them chesses the game is
still really [ __ ] complicated like i
mean something [ __ ] oh I need that night
oh I need getting the time I didn't get
into oh my god I want a [ __ ] crying
[Music]
I want to cry oh my god is the worst
feeling I'm done
I'm so [ __ ] done oh my god I'm so
[ __ ] done with this game having
virtually nothing to do with defending
ancients or chess in terms of actual
gameplay Auto chess is more of a mix
between battle bots and a turn-based
strategy game it's because of this that
after attracting some of DotA's most
notable streamers the game started to
catch the attention of hearthstone and
Magic the Gathering players Wow hey so
p.m. things like happy Charles so I sold
everything
since Auto chess is basically a trading
card game without the cards it quickly
established itself as the TCG
community's newest obsession within a
month of its release Auto chest became
one of the most popular games on Steam
it's currently sitting at over 6 and a
half million subscribers and it's
estimated to be one of the top 5 most
played games on Steam it has its own
wiki subreddit at which category and
even had its own twitch rivals event
moments away from getting into our first
match here and we might have some people
watching who have never played this game
before and as difficult as it is to
explain I'd like to give it a shot of
trying to kind of just dumb it down give
me dota Auto chess for dummies not since
the rise of dota 1 has a mod seen such
unfathomable success and that's kind of
what's incredible here that auto chess
is gonna do 2 dota 2 what dota did to
Warcraft 3 it used to be that people
would run out to buy the Frozen Throne
so they could play a silly 7 megabyte
map called Defense of the Ancients now
people were installing its successor to
play in the equally explosive auto chest
have you seen sizing before oh my god
what No we can actually make this a
first time ever
[Music]
one community even one so far is to give
it a Warcraft 3 skin naturally people
started to wonder would valve buy up
auto chests or would they ignore it just
like Blizzard ignored the original dose
and given artifact colossal failure it
seemed like valve might be interested
they dumped years of development time
and millions of dollars into a dota
centric TCG and then they were
outclassed by five guys with a map
editor now it's not exactly clear what
happened to team valve and Rodo there
were reports that a valve was interested
in buying auto chests but according to
an AMA that wrote oh did the dota2
developer was too busy vacationing
Gerudo also claimed that there were
several other big companies trying to
buy them out and made a specific point
of stating that they wouldn't work with
$0.10 who in addition to owning Riot
Games recently put out a survey asking
if fans would play an auto chess clone
instead of valve or $0.10 Drogo
partnered with a lesser-known publisher
called Dragon Nest
they also partnered with enmity v who
want to turn auto chance into a global
eSport she's awesome at it
yeah she's wonderful I was saying this
earlier I'm I'm being from the fgc this
like being each sports is so weird to me
yeah
each sports right [ __ ] come on there we
go GC communities it's not like the
tourney sports they do that given its
incredible popularity in China there's a
pretty good chance an auto chest could
become the most popular game in the
world but Jurado aren't the only ones
who are aware of that reportedly eight
companies are trying to trademark the
term auto chess including 10-cent
but if garoto are able to stick the
landing hella struck complete by
choosing not to partner with a big
company like valve or ten cent they'll
be able to reap the full rewards of
their labor as for whether these
underdogs will sink or swim well we'll
just have to wait and see thanks for
watching if you want more great content
just like this be sure to hit the
subscribe button
[Music]